"The Treasury Department is your
symbol of service and protection."
"And has been since 1789."
"Its responsibilities are great
and its duties far-reaching."
"Through its subdivisions it comes in
direct contact with every U.S. citizen."
"The Treasury Department maintains the
oldest U.S. Navy fleet. The Coastguard."
"It controls merchandise crossing our
borders, and prevents smuggling."
"It is responsible for the
collection of internal revenue."
"Enforces federal narcotic laws."
"Suppresses counterfeiting."
"And finally, engraves and
prints the money you use."
"Making paper money requires the precise
skill of many artists and engravers."
"No one employee engraves
the complete design."
"All the separate engravings are finally
combined to form one composite design."
"From which is prepared the multiple
plates used in the actual printing."
"Here, still another
specialist is involved."
"The printer. Expertly polishing the
plate with the palms of his hands."
"So that only clear,
sharp images will result."
"The sheets of notes pass through
trained fingers under practised eyes."
"As one complicated
process after another .."
"Sends them on their
way to final completion."
"If a counterfeiter were to duplicate
exactly a United States banknote."
"He would have to possess not only
the combined skills of many artists."
"But all he elaborate
equipment as well."
"For, there is no question .."
"That each individual note made here .."
"Represents the finest example
of the engraver's art."
"Yet counterfeiters have been
trying to duplicate U.S. currency .."
"From revolutionary days right on up."
"These are counterfeit notes picked up
by the Service over the past 85 years."
"Despite the fact that each can be
detected by careful and alert citizens."
"Thousands of people are
needlessly victimized every year."
"Mostly the general public."
"Small merchants and
Neighborhood trades people."
Well Mrs Flaherty, how's business?
As good as new. We get a nice crowd.
Our dinner trade is awful slow though.
It will pick up.
- Of course it will.
If I do say so myself,
we set a fine table.
You ought to come over some time.
I will. Next week maybe.
Excuse me.
Fred.
That's one of them alright.
- Thanks.
Is something wrong?
Mrs Flaherty, do you remember
where you got that bill?
The twenty?
Around noon. In the rush
hour. I was very busy.
A young, dark fellow with a mustache.
It's good isn't it?
- It's counterfeit.
Counterfeit?
You should watch for these things.
Especially in a bill of this size.
I've got to turn this in
to the Secret Service.
I can have it back, can't I?
- I'm afraid not.
You are just down twenty dollars.
But I can't afford it. I don't see how
they can expect me to take this loss.
People who handle money have to
learn to spot the bad when they see it.
It's their only protection.
I'm awfully sorry.
"Mrs Flaherty's bill was sent to the
Secret Service Laboratory, Washington."
"Here, counterfeit bills are analyzed
for distinctive characteristics."
"Mrs Flaherty's bill, it turned out .."
"Had some very distinctive and
rather familiar characteristics."
Remember this note, Chief?
Yes .. the old Stewart note.
No. Don't tell me this has
come out of retirement?
Yes. After three years. A new crop, too.
A million of these phonies floating
around isn't a happy idea, is it.
It's fresh alright. Almost perfect.
You think Stewart would know about this?
- He might.
He didn't have the plates.
We knew that when he took the rap.
That case was a heart-breaker.
It will break your heart again if they
flood the country with this stuff.
Why don't you drop in
on him? He might talk.
His address is still Atlanta.
- Why not? We haven't any choice.
Stewart hasn't got such a
bad record here, has he?
Very good. A model prisoner.
He's too sharp to break any small rules.
I'll talk to him now.
Bring Stewart in.
- "Yes, sir."
He's got another seven years to go.
He'll be out in four and
a half with his good time.
That's all, Guard.
Stewart.
This is Mr Raymond of the
United States Secret Service.
You don't seem very glad to see me.
Sit down. Mr Raymond
wants to talk to you.
Familiar?
What would I do with money in here?
Look at it.
A twenty-dollar bill.
A couple of bets, or a ten-dollar win.
Or a tip to the cigarette girl.
Ah, Stewart .. don't snub an old friend.
At your arrest, you had $50,000 of those
twenties, all phony, in your possession.
I did?
Just because you got caught,
don't get sore at the money.
I'm not sore.
- Okay, but it so happens that we are.
The bills are popping
up again, mostly out west.
Frisco, Reno, Vegas and L.A.
- It wasn't me.
I don't think so. Come again.
Maybe you figure .. I've been
floating them out the window.
Don't kid with me. You know what I mean.
Somebody has got those plates
and is circulating the money.
You might know who that somebody is.
- I don't get around socially anymore.
Stewart, you've got
seven more years to go.
A little cooperation
might cut that down.
It might even get you a
recommendation for an early parole.
Stoolpigeons don't
live long, Mr Raymond.
I don't expect you to be a stoolpigeon.
I'm asking you to be loyal to yourself.
To think of your own welfare.
The mob is in action again,
but what are they doing for you?
Nothing.
What are you doing for them?
Seven more years.
Who's printing that counterfeit money?
I didn't know then and I don't know now.
- Who was your contact man?
He was a guy named .. Joe.
He always wore dark glasses and had
his hat pulled down low over his face.
If he had a face I never saw it.
I guess I couldn't really tell
you what he looked like.
Is that all you have to tell me?
Stewart, I guess I owe you an apology.
For interrupting your routine and
dragging you into the Warden's office.
I misjudged you completely.
You must really like it here.
You like it well enough to consider it
home-sweet-home for the next 7 years.
Alright, Warden.
Think of the next 7 years, Stewart.
Try to refresh your memory.
Come on, Stewart.
What do you think?
Oh, I think he'll come around.
"One week later, on a
Federal district court order."
"Tris Stewart was being
transferred to Kansas City .."
"In the custody of the
U.S. Deputy Marshals."
No rest for the wicked.
I'm doing alright.
Do you mind raising your flipper?
It's central time now.
We've gained an hour.
- Yeah?
I can sure use it.
Alright, unlock the jewelry.
Get up.
Pull her up and stop.
Go easy on those brakes.
What you waiting for? Open the door.
The gun is empty.
Hand it over.
Come on, give me.
- Afraid I'm going to hurt myself?
If anybody ever looks
sideways at you, Stewart.
No, not this trip. I do what I'm told.
A Marshall and me sure put
on a good act in any case.
I'll start cheering when
you give us some results.
In case you are wondering,
I've got another gun here.
Loaded.
What's the matter? Don't you trust me?
Calling SS 972.
Calling SS 972. Over.
[ Radio: ]
"SS972."
"Go ahead."
Agent Foreman reporting.
On Highway 40. I've got the boy.
"Did everything go alright?"
- Yeah, no trouble.
Perfect cooperation.
"Good. Keep checking with us."
Right. When we get to Kansas City.
Well, how's it feel to be free?
- I'm not complaining.
Why should you.
You're getting a square shake.
All we want are those plates.
And your pals.
- Don't worry. I'll find them.
Only give me a little time.
The quicker you do it, the quicker
you'll be considered for parole.
We'll keep our end of the bargain.
- Listen, I'm pulling my end, too.
Only keep out of my hair. I got a
lot of contacts to look up. Old leads.
It won't help any with
you tagging along.
Sorry, when we catch this bunch.
We're going to be so close together.
When you scratch your back,
you'll be scratching mine.
Get used to it, Stewart.
Long distance?
That call to Chicago.
Fred Simpson. Any answer yet?
Keep checking on it.
Bill Bryce is out. He'll call me back.
That call to Chicago
is still on ice, too.
The operator will keep checking.
You're doing great.
- Yeah .. gum?
No thanks.
By the way, whatever happened to
your old girlfriend, Meg Dixon?
Not a bad looking dame.
- Let me see.
Nosy bird, aren't you?
Where is she now, Tris?
Not in Detroit. We checked there.
- No. Not Detroit. She got married.
Last I heard she was living
up north, raising a family.
You're lying. That's for sure.
Okay, you tell me then.
"I wonder what's become of Meg."
Sounds like the title to a song.
Ah!
Cut yourself?
- Yeah, that crummy glass.
Let's have a look.
Thank you.
- You're quite welcome.
Hey Laurie. Some cigarettes, please.
Laurie.
Thank you.
I'll take the usual, Laurie.
How you doing?
- Not bad, Mr Hackett.
I don't have the right change in the
tin. I'll have to give you some singles.
Keep it. I don't like a lot of singles.
Too bulky.
They weigh me down.
You travel light, don't you, Mr Hackett.
Well, I travel.
I may be moving on if you
don't show a little interest.
Los Angeles is one
town I can do without.
Be careful. You're talking
to a native daughter.
I might report you.
Say, when you do, tell them I don't
like their brand of hospitality.
A guy can die of lonesomeness here.
Try hanging on a while, won't you?
You might change your mind.
That's quite a guy.
He must own a dozen oil wells, or he
thinks cigarettes are ten bucks a pack.
If he told me he was
lonesome I'd encourage him.
You mean, if he were a girl?
- Sure ..
Hello.
Well hello. I thought your
big night was over.
I hope not.
Not yet, anyway.
I .. I thought you might
need a little protection.
Yeah? From whom?
Oh, from lone wolves.
Maybe a wolf pack, even.
Oh, that's very nice of you,
but who protects me from you?
Say .. look at me.
Don't you see .. character
written in this face?
Ah, you are a sort of a character.
But I prefer to go home
alone if you don't mind.
Well.
Shall we say goodnight or wait until?
- Until what?
Until a Patrol Car comes
along and I yell at them.
I'll go quietly.
I don't want anything to disturb what's
going to be a delightful relationship.
You can hope .. just like anyone else.
I guess.
It's me. Tris.
- Oh, honey!
Oh I was so worried.
I read about you in the papers.
I thought they'd find you.
Who was the creep following you?
Nobody. Just a barnacle
who hangs around the club.
What happened?
I'll tell you later. Where do you live?
- Not far.
Come on.
I'm out on a prayer.
The Feds tapped me for a stoolpigeon.
They even sprung me, the dopes.
Then I sprung one on them.
Imagine. Tris Stewart
playing ball with the cops.
All they got left now is some
blind-alley tips and empty bags.
No cream, sugar.
What do you mean, no cream and no sugar?
Confusing, eh?
Oh, I'm so glad you're back.
I like it.
I like you, too.
Tell me.
Anybody been prowling around?
Cops I mean. Asking questions?
No. Nobody.
Not since I moved out here and changed
my name to Laurie Fredericks.
That's good.
We'll work fast.
We strike .. then Mexico for keeps.
Does that sound good?
- How soon can we do it?
First I've got to get in touch
with my ex-partner, Sam Hooker.
That dirty rat getting rich off my
plates while I rot in the pen.
I'll pay him a little surprise
visit tomorrow morning.
It won't take a lot to
make a deal with him.
And after that, baby.
It's Mexico for you and me.
Yes?
Oh, Brown?
Sure. Go ahead.
Just like that, huh?
Tomorrow? Good work.
Alright. Stay with it.
Well, if they took a census tonight we'd
have one more bad citizen in our midst.
Let me guess.
Would it be my ex roommate, Stewart?
None other. Just flew in.
He's with the Fredericks girl right now.
I'd like have ten minutes alone with him
after the mauling he gave me in Kansas.
On the house, too.
As they say, orders are orders.
Yeah, but I'd still like ten
minutes alone with him.
The orders didn't read:
"Pull my punches".
I could flatten him a dozen times.
Sure you could. And you'd still be
listening to him making phone calls.
And we'd still be
tracking down false leads.
Except for you pride,
it's better this way.
Is this private?
- Not at all. Nice to see you, Johnny.
I want you to meet Fred Foreman.
This is John Downey.
Glad to know you.
You don't want to let Stewart
give you the slip in Kansas City.
Good luck, Johnny. When you see Stewart,
give him ten bells from me will you.
Looking forward to it.
I've got news for you.
Stewart is in town.
How?
And where is he?
Well, at the moment he's with the girl.
Oh.
Don't look so unhappy.
After all, it's his girl.
I'm beginning to realize that.
Cigarette?
- No, thanks.
What's the matter? She dump you?
- Just a tip.
You see, I'm losing my touch.
- Maybe you never had it.
Or else she's too smart for you.
How about it?
- No. I don't think so.
As far as she and everyone at the club
is concerned, I'm just Johnny Hackett.
A very shady character.
If they look me up.
I've been everything from cardsharp to a
confidence man and a record to prove it.
I know Hackett's tricks.
Every night he went home
and robbed his own mother.
Well, I haven't done that yet.
Now, according to the report.
Stewart starts moving in the morning.
He's after the plates.
Fine .. and who has the plates?
Ever hear of Sam Hooker?
Uhuh.
[ Door knocks ]
Who do you want?
A better welcome, I'd say.
Do I have to blast my way
in to see my old partner?
Well, I've been ..
Wake up. Open your eyes.
Don't you remember me?
Oh I remember. It's you, Tris.
I didn't recognize
you right off the bat.
It's been such a long time.
Didn't you know I was out?
No.
No but .. I haven't
been feeling well, Tris.
I don't get around much anymore.
I stay pretty close to home.
But .. now that you're back.
What do you say you and
me have a little drink, huh?
Have a drink, Tris.
This isn't exactly a social call.
But you are glad to see
me, aren't you, Tris?
That all depends.
On what?
When I was your partner,
what you did to me.
I've been doing time for
the two of us, remember?
I gave you a chance to draw a sweet
bank loan for us. Where's my share?
Lost, Tris. But I can ..
Where's the plates?
Have a little drink, Tris.
- Where are they?
I sold them.
You thought I was as good as buried?
- No, no. Don't, Tris.
I was going to stash them away but ..
But things got awfully tough
after they nailed you .. and ..
The plates was hot and I got
scared and I lost my nerve and ..
And I sold them.
Where's my cut?
I lost it. Just like I lost mine.
I lost all the dough on the
ponies, cards and dice.
My luck's been awful bad.
You don't know how bad.
Who's got the plates?
I don't know.
- Try and remember!
Does his name come to you now, huh?
Sylvester.
Jack Sylvester.
Sylvester, huh?
- Yes ..
He used to be one of our pals.
Where is he now?
I don't know.
You'd better find out.
He lives in Hollywood.
The Grant Building.
Tris, don't!
Tris, don't ..
Looking for someone?
Is Jack Sylvester in?
Business or personal?
A little bit of both.
Who wants to see him?
Just tell him it's an old friend.
A fellow outside.
Says he's an old friend.
What's he look like?
Hello, Jack.
It's okay, Mack.
Ain't you glad to see me?
Sure. Terrific.
You should have phoned me.
I could have met you someplace.
I don't like you coming here.
Relax, Sylvester.
Gum?
Would I bring a load of
trouble to an old friend?
I came to L.A. because they are
looking for me in Kansas City.
There's two thousand miles
between me and a pinch.
You could be wrong. Of course I'm
just telling you for your own good.
Well.
What's on your mind, Tris?
I'd like to get in action again.
I figured you could help me.
Maybe.
I suppose you know that Sam
clipped me for those plates.
That's too bad.
- Yeah, isn't it.
But you got the plates.
So what?
So I'd like to buy a little merchandise.
Listen, Tris.
You're on your uppers and what you're
talking about takes real dough to plan.
I know that.
I can raise it.
Got to be strictly cash and carry
and nothing less than 25 G's ..
I'll tell you something.
Nothing less.
Okay. I'll raise the 25 G's.
Though I'll need a little eating money.
There's a pair.
Okay .. I'll be back with the 25 G's.
Cash on the line.
That dame must eat, sleep
and wash to Rumba music.
She sure loves her South American way.
You'd think the record
would break or wear out.
"What happened? Did you see Hooker?"
"Yeah, I saw him. He threw me out."
Then Jack Sylvester.
So, I had a little talk with Sylvester.
I think we got a deal cooking.
Honey, please don't take any chances.
I've been worried all afternoon.
- Stop worrying. I know what I'm doing.
Are you sure you weren't followed?
- You can never be sure.
Anyway, I'm taking precautions.
I've been changing from street cars to
cabs to buses all in about five miles.
You got a cold beer in the house?
Yeah, there's some in the icebox.
Relax.
Now.
You know, they say Mexico
is a wonderful place to relax.
I read about it.
Yeah.
And I'll tell you what else
it's a wonderful place for.
American money.
Good old dollars. Down there
they're starving for it.
I can push a quarter million with
the phony money just like that.
I'd settle for half of that.
- Half? All of it, baby.
Only trouble is, I've got to
have real dough to swing it.
Everybody has that trouble, honey.
It's the one thing in the world
there is never enough of.
You know what I need?
I need a nice friendly safe.
Forget it. I don't think we
could risk anything like that.
Safes can be real trouble.
- Not if you know how to open them.
Tell me, baby.
What's the weekend take
of that club of yours, huh?
I don't know.
- Yes, you do. Come on, tell me.
- Tell me!
Sometimes 17 to 18 thousand
but honey I'm afraid.
"You'll help? You love me, don't you?"
"You know I do. But can
you get away with me?"
"Maybe with your help."
If Stewart tries to pull off this
job, he'll get killed, or jail.
Not good.
We'll just have to stop him or write
off everything we've done so far.
We just can't afford to let
this man jam himself up.
He won't if we work fast.
It may be just what we need.
Get me the Hollywood Police station.
- "Yes, sir."
Am I tired.
You sure enjoyed it tonight, Sam.
- You can say that again.
Goodnight, Laurie. See you tomorrow.
- Goodnight Mr Baker.
Goodnight.
- Goodnight, Sam.
You know what to, don't you?
When you come out of the parking lot to
the club, I start driving towards you.
Right. No slip up.
Tris, I'm terribly frightened.
- Stop it. It's no time for the jitters.
All you have to do is start this
car when you see me coming.
Maybe we'd better forget it.
There's too many cops crawling around.
Suppose something happened?
Suppose you get hurt?
If anybody gets hurt, it won't be me.
Not as long as I've got a gun.
Just remember to start the engine
when you see me coming.
Having trouble, lady?
No. I just can't start my car.
I guess the engine's at fault.
The first lesson in driving is
to turn on your ignition.
Oh, yes.
What are you doing here
at this time of the morning?
Nothing. I just work over at the
club and I'm on my way home.
Who's your boyfriend?
What boyfriend?
- The man that just got out of your car.
Why, he didn't get out of my car.
- Pick him up.
Stop!
Well Laurie, everything squared away?
Yeah Johnny, thanks to you.
- Ah, forget it.
I waited a long time for a date.
But I didn't think I'd need
an arrest to swing it.
How much do I owe you?
- 300 will take care of my end.
Fair enough.
Thanks. If there is any more
trouble, I give 24 hour service.
Goodbye.
- Goodbye.
Well, Laurie.
That is that, to coin a phrase.
You really came through for me, Johnny.
Why not? I've been
in these spots myself.
I don't want to kid you, Johnny.
Someone depends an awful lot on me.
Yeah? Well, he hasn't
been much help to you.
Why don't you ditch the guy?
Because he needs me.
And he needs a break.
He's got you .. puts him one up on me.
I'd go all out, Laurie.
If it would help you.
- That's swell of you.
But only you.
I'm selfish about everything but money.
I just happen to have a little loose
change burning a hole in my pocket.
That puts you in a class by yourself.
Yeah .. but I'd rather not be by myself.
It's more fun spending it
when you've got some help.
How about it?
Well, it's an interesting idea.
Think it over.
You can always meet me
at the Hotel Marguerite.
[ Door knocks ]
Okay. It's me, Tris.
Are you alright?
- Yeah.
What happened? I was worried.
Nothing. Sorry I had to run out on
you that way. But what could I do?
Worked out fine. And you're out, too.
- Sure, it was just like that.
All it took was 300 bucks,
a lawyer and a good friend.
Yeah? Who's the good friend?
- Johnny Hackett, the guy at the club.
And you said he didn't
mean anything to you?
He doesn't, I say.
- Well, what's he after?
Nothing, he's not after anything.
What's the matter? You ought
to be glad I got a friend.
Well, I'm not, see. I don't like
the way this guy is moving in.
You're crazy. Just because a guy happens
to like me you start getting ideas.
I'd have been in a swell spot
if he hadn't come through.
Alright.
What's his pitch, then?
I think he's lying low.
I know for sure he's loaded.
He spends big, tips big ..
- And he talks big. Don't they all?
You think he's a racket guy?
You don't make that kind
of dough selling bibles.
You might be right.
- It's what I've tried to tell you.
What are you going to do?
Look this guy up. He might be
interested in a proposition.
From me this time.
Tris honey, please let me
handle it. You don't know him.
It's time we met.
Where does this guy hang out?
Besides the club?
It's the Marguerite hotel,
but please honey, be careful.
I'll see you later.
What is this?
What's the idea of
making a play for my girl?
What you talking about?
Laurie Fredericks. The girl at the club.
Get up.
Next time you even take a look
at her, I'll cool you for keeps.
If you didn't have a gun on me,
I'd beat your brains out.
Cheap penny-alley grifter.
Oh, I see.
So you're big-time, huh?
I've been rummaging through your gear.
By the looks of things,
you're not too big.
Cold cards. Cold dice. I'd say there was
quite a bit of room for improvement.
I'm doing alright.
- Yeah?
How would you like
to do a little better?
I don't like guns.
I had something else in mind.
- Well, keep it there.
You'll get it.
How would you like to fit
yourself into a good deal?
Sorry .. I don't make
deals with strangers.
Especially when their
name is Tris Stewart.
What difference does that make?
I read about that break.
You're pretty hot.
You ought to be hiding out.
Nah.
Not when there is a big
jackpot ripe to be taken.
All I need is the right combination.
You might be it.
Listen, if you thought that, why did
you open with a punch on my nose?
I was griping at you.
I bet you I can make you forget
that when you hear my offer.
Okay, make it. I'm listening.
Okay.
If I had 25 G's I could stretch
it to a quarter of a million.
Don't interrupt.
That quarter million is phony.
But it's so good it
would pass in a bank.
And I already got the
territory to operate.
That's one racket I know, brother.
- Ha. So does the government.
Look who's talking.
I suppose they don't know
about you and your racket?
This way you'd at least make a strike.
Besides, I take all the risk.
Even so, I don't like tangling
with counterfeit dough.
Once you burn your fingers on that,
it takes a long time to heal.
Didn't I just say I do all the work?
All you have to do is rustle
up the 25 G's. Can you?
Well, the amount doesn't worry me.
It's just that it's out of my line.
Let me think it over.
Think hard. I'll know where to find you.
Drop in, later.
If you want to punch a thing, punch the
door first. I'll wake up just as quick.
No hard feelings.
I've never heard of
this guy Johnny Hackett.
Maybe you don't get
around like you used to.
His front business is cardsharp.
Get some more dope on him.
He and Bugsy McGill used
to work smuggling together.
A pleasure boat.
They made three successful trips.
Before the captains got wise to them
and invited them to travel by rowboat.
Bring him in.
Hackett, this is Sylvester. Say
hello boys. Let's get down to cases.
How are you?
- Hello.
By "cases" he means "money", Hackett.
I understand you're ready.
That depends .. mind
if I see the attraction?
Try that for size.
The skin you love to touch.
I have never yet seen
its equal, Hackett.
I have.
In any cash drawer. This is genuine.
What are you trying to pull on me?
Ha-ha .. he thinks it's the McCoy.
How do you like that?
And you said you knew what
a queer looks like. Are you kidding?
No. It looks real. Let me see it again.
Hackett. You're looking
at the cream of the crop.
It's a plenty fine job, and
Uncle Sam didn't make it.
Look at the border .. those sharp lines.
This one is on the level.
Compare them.
See the difference?
I guess I owe you an apology.
Yes. It's queer alright.
But you have to look awful close.
Sorry I didn't stumble
it the first time.
But I had to be sure.
- Oh, think nothing of it.
I'd have done the same
thing in your place.
Well I .. gather you're sold?
Next problem is delivery.
Any ideas, Tris?
Hackett is going to
draw the dough first.
That will be tomorrow.
How about us meeting
at a place in town, huh?
Sure. Any time after the banks open.
Around noon?
- Noon is fine.
Suppose we contact in Hollywood?
Some place along Fountain Avenue?
Alright. How about between Crescent
Heights and Hayworth? On the north side.
Fine.
Alright with you, Hackett?
- Whatever you say.
It's a deal, then. Noon tomorrow.
"Go ahead, John."
- The deal is on.
Delivery will be made
at 12 noon tomorrow.
Stewart and I will park
on Fountain Avenue.
Between Crescent Heights and Hayworth.
North side of the street.
It looks like the real thing.
"We'll have the place staked out.
Every man will be covering you."
Don't close in until you actually see
my money pass into the receiver's hands.
That will be the signal.
- "Right, Johnny."
When I see you hand over the
money, that will be my cue.
My boys won't move until I tell them.
Good luck.
Now, you all have your positions.
I'll be in front of the grocery store.
When I see our agent
hand over the money.
I'll take a beer case off the
stack and set it on the sidewalk.
That will be your signal to close in.
When it touches the
sidewalk. Not before.
Now I want it understood, that nobody
makes a move until you get the signal.
If you jump the gun .. you
can blow this whole case.
And maybe lose a man.
So keep your eyes on me. Is that clear?
Alright.
And have your standby cars ready.
They may try a getaway.
That's all, gentlemen.
Cagey, isn't he?
He thinks it might be a trap.
I like guys that are careful.
It means less chance of a slip-up.
Yeah, but I want to get
it over with and get going.
Hiya, Tris.
Hello, Hackett.
- Hello.
You got your money?
- Right here.
So, let's see one.
Wait ..
Just a minute.
Good.
Okay.
Let's have the package.
How about my payoff?
Hey, what's the idea?
What do you mean, Tris?
- Package is just scrap paper.
Because I had to be sure.
It might be a trap.
You I know, Hackett, I don't.
You knucklehead.
Pulling a test-run on me.
Now cool off.
There's nothing new about a test run.
Just playing safe.
Yeah, well let's stop playing.
Hackett is on the up and up.
And I'm running out of patience.
When do we deal?
You'll hear from me.
You're okay in my books, Hackett.
How careful can you get?
I'll explain it to you later.
Let's get out of here.
I can sure use this.
What a day.
- Yeah.
Here is to money and
the time to spend it.
I'll drink to that. Real money.
And no more test-runs.
You can say that again.
I'm a little mixed up .. I thought you
guys were in a hurry to make a deal.
Do you always waste time like this?
Let's face it. Sylvester wasn't sure.
Why?
You might have been
working with the cops.
Okay, suppose you were
they you made a pinch.
All they'd have got would have been
a bundle of paper. Plain paper.
You can't get a conviction on that.
Try it sometime.
I'm not in that business,
thanks. I play for keeps.
Well so do we, Johnny.
He just didn't want to take
any chances, that's all.
You're in now, Hackett.
Next trip, it will be the
real thing. No more paper.
Okay, I'm ready when they are,
but the sooner the better.
When do you deal, Tris?
- As soon as I hear from Sylvester.
I'll get a hold of you, don't worry.
Thanks for the drink.
I'll see you at the club.
I'll be at the bar, spending real money.
And for that, you get real service.
And Hackett, you can forget
about those ten-buck tips.
You're a member of the family now.
Kind of a brother.
Thanks. That makes it easier.
And don't forget, that
makes Laurie your sister.
Treat her that way.
That's not too easy.
Good evening, Mr Hackett.
- Good evening, Laurie.
This way, please.
- Thank you.
Johnny. Johnny Downey.
How you been, Johnny?
- Afraid you got the wrong party, pal.
Oh, not a chance.
Oh, Betty. Betty, come here.
It's been a long time.
I want you to meet the wife. Betty ..
This is Johnny Downey.
- You're making a mistake.
My name is Hackett.
Hackett? OH, don't give me that.
You're Johnny Downey.
The guy is plastered.
Leave him alone, Bill.
- I'd appreciate it.
Look, I'm expecting somebody.
Oh .. oh, I get it.
Come on Betty. The man
is right. He's not Downey.
Sorry, pal. I should have known.
What was that all about?
- I'll tell you when we get seated.
Thank you.
He's a government agent.
- A government agent?
Probably undercover.
I hope I didn't tip his hand.
You and your mysterious friends.
I tell you Betty, I knew him
when he was in the army.
Military Intelligence.
Before that he was
in the Secret Service.
What a dope I am.
- Why don't you admit you got the brush?
Waiter, two Scotch and sodas, please.
Yes, madam.
Secret Service? Huh!
Say, you're home early.
Those records I rented
gave me the creeps.
Tris, I left some packages out in the
hall. Will you help me with them?
I think there is a talking risk.
Tris, Hackett is a cop. His real
name is Downey. Secret Service.
Who told you that?
- Customers.
They were talking and they said he
was an agent with the government.
I thought the room might be wired, so ..
- Alright, let's find out.
You be quiet.
It's all over.
He knows about everything.
Yeah, he knows too much.
- What are we going to do?
We'll play along. I've still
got to get my 25 G's.
No, I'm frightened.
Let's get out while we can.
We'll get out alright, don't worry. But
Hackett is going to pay our expenses.
Now this is what you do.
You stay here tonight.
And first thing tomorrow morning
buy us two tickets to Mexico City.
The evening plane.
Use the name "Rodney".
Where are you going?
I've got other business to attend to.
I'll meet you at the airport restaurant.
Got the name straight?
- "Rodney", yeah.
That's right. Now, when
you leave use the back door.
Make sure that you are not tailed.
[ Door knocks ]
Ah hello, Stewart.
- What's up?
Just heard from Sylvester.
He says to meet him
at one o'clock sharp.
Where?
In front of the hotel.
Then he'll take us to the spot.
- Well, that figures.
Want some coffee?
- Nope.
You .. got the dough?
Not on me.
I don't make a practice of lining
my pockets with 25 G's in cash.
After the last .. rehearsal,
I put it back in the vault.
Well, you'd better get dressed.
Then we'll go down and take it out.
Get the money?
- Uhuh.
We'd better go back to the
hotel and wait for Sylvester.
No, let's just keep moving.
Might be wiser.
What's the matter? Anything wrong?
Could be. Never can tell.
You think we'd better call off the deal?
I already called it off.
You're kidding?
No, Hackett. You remind me of somebody.
Like who?
- Like a Secret Service agent.
Now keep driving.
Don't be a fool, Stewart.
What you want to muff a good chance for?
- A chance for what? To play stoolie?
That's the deal, Stewart.
That's why you're out.
And that's why I'm staying out.
On my own terms, too.
You had yourself quite
a time, didn't you.
Playing a hotshot gambler, tipping heavy
for smokes. Making a play for my girl.
Why not think of your girl,
Stewart? Give her a break.
Why don't you shut up.
Pretty lucky for me,
I found you out when I did.
You know, you're the only link
between me and your Federal buddies.
That's a link I'm going to have to cut.
Just keep driving.
I want to show you a beautiful view.
Take the money out.
Throw it on the back seat.
Follow me out.
Come on.
Book him. Assault with intent
to kill. I'll sign the complaint.
Put him where he can't talk to anybody.
Don't worry, if he wants to talk
he'll have to talk to himself.
Oh .. book him under another name.
Just tell the newspaper boys he's
a hitchhiker who tried a stick-up.
We don't want any publicity on this.
How does the name of "Blake" sound?
- Good as any.
Agent-in-charge Gunby, please.
It's my mother-in-law's name.
I just liked to see how it would
look on a Police blotter.
Mr Gunby?
This is Downey.
Stewart was tipped off.
I'll explain later how it happened. I'll
book Stewart in at the Police station.
Well, there goes the case.
Wait a minute. It's not dead yet.
Why can't I go ahead without Stewart?
That's pretty risky.
Without him along,
they'll be too suspicious.
That's the chance I'll take.
Stewart can't tip them now.
My big worry is Laurie Fredericks.
She could fix me good.
Unless you pick her up
before I contact Sylvester.
Alright. We'll do that for you.
But it's your idea.
Where do you meet Sylvester?
- "At his office."
That's it, then.
We'll be right behind
as you leave with him.
Good luck.
Curry speaking.
This is Gunby.
Is Laurie Fredericks
in her apartment now?
I think so. We're getting
music from her room.
Just continue your present operation.
Pick her up immediately
and bring her to my office.
Yes, sir.
Gunby says to pick the
Fredericks girl right away.
Looks like she's gone.
Her clothes are gone, too.
Well, we'd better make a report.
Hang up quick.
- Just a minute, Tony.
You got a wild hair or
something? What's up?
They picked up Stewart.
Were you there?
- No. Laurie saw it.
Stewart was just leaving her place.
A plainclothes man took him.
She phoned my right away.
When did they take him?
- About an hour ago.
Plain clothes, huh?
Breaking Stewart out
of prison was a mistake.
Yeah, and it's putting Secret Service
agents out on a counterfeit tip.
How could they get a lead on us?
- How? How do they ever?
Now Stewart's hotter than a firecracker.
He can explode and take us with him.
Stewart will never talk.
I don't trust anybody not to talk.
Not when the clamps are really on.
[ Telephone ]
I wouldn't answer that, Sylvester.
They're probably getting set for a
raid right now. Trying to locate you.
[ Telephone ]
Look, Sylvester. I took a
long chance to tip you off.
We haven't got any time to waste.
- What's on your mind?
I'm going to lose myself for good. But
first, let's go through with our deal.
Where I'm going I can peddle all
kinds of queer without a question.
Yeah. That's a good idea.
I think I'll find myself
a cave somewhere.
I'm waiting for Mack to get me.
- You won't have to wait.
My car is downstairs. Come on.
But operator, a minute
ago I got a busy signal.
There's a car that's been
with us a little too long.
Take the next corner.
Are you sure?
- Yeah, I see it.
Take the next corner
easy and then step on it.
Is he still behind us?
- I can't see him now.
I thought he was going to turn with us.
- You probably imagined it.
I never did see any car.
- Maybe.
Stop at the first handy bar you see.
- I thought we were going to the place?
Later. Tonight.
Right now, I need a drink.
Okay.
Hello.
This is Jack. I guess the
Stewart girl saw him picked up.
Hackett and I are on our
way over to the plant.
Get everything out of that
office and check with me later.
Right.
Looking for Tris Stewart. Is he here?
- Who are you?
I'm his girl. I thought he was here.
- Wait a minute.
You say you're looking for Stewart?
- Yeah. I've got to find him right away.
Something is wrong
here that don't add up.
What do you mean?
- I don't know.
But I'd better let the
boss handle it. Come on.
Can't you use a phone?
Listen sister, where we're
going they don't use.
How far do we have to go?
- To the car park.
This is like looking for
a needle in a haystack.
Try the downtown area.
We've covered this.
Yes, sir.
With the Fredericks girl on the
loose Downey won't have a chance.
Unless we can get to
him before she does.
Well, you're close to transportation.
You can always take a trolley.
When this over, I'm taking a boat.
What's this all about?
- We're changing our plans, Al.
But you would deliver it next?
They got Stewart. We'll do the transfer
now and go. Close the shop. Everything.
In here.
Finish up, boys. We're going. Pack it
all in the truck. Let's get out of here.
I'll give you a hand.
Same as the sample.
Yeah .. I guess so.
Alright. Let's have your money.
Mind if I see the rest of the parcel?
What's the matter? You afraid
we'll short change you?
For 25 grand I like to be sure.
No offence.
Okay .. but don't take
all night about it.
Come on. We'll walk from here.
It measures up, doesn't it?
- So far, great.
With these, I could start my
own private Marshall Plan.
In South America.
Meet my family. Mama and Papa.
Hey, those are beautiful.
Mind if I take a look?
- Not at all.
Hackett, you're looking at masterpieces.
I take great pride in these plates.
Look at the scroll work,
the meticulous care.
Yeah, they're real works of art.
Treasures .. like paintings.
- I think so.
But anyone can own prints of paintings.
I happen to prefer the .. originals.
At least they're
identical in that respect.
Would you happen to know who made these?
No .. I'm sorry.
The artist neglected to sign his name.
Yeah, I'm sorry, too.
Must look him up some day.
Want to sell these?
- No. Not a chance, Hackett.
These are my old-age pension.
The only things better
than money are the plates.
Just make them.
- Yeah.
Tell the boss to come out here.
I got to see him right away.
Okay.
Mack's outside with the girl.
He wants to see you right away.
What's this all about? Who's she?
- This is Tris Stewart's girl.
Why did you bring her here? You know
better than that.         - Now, listen.
I've got to find Tris. Is he here?
- What are you saying?
You know what happened to him.
- I haven't seen him since last night.
Who are you kidding?
You told Hackett you
saw him get pinched.
I didn't tell him anything.
Don't you know Hackett is a cop?
Ask Tris. He knows all about it.
- Hackett is a cop?
Yes he is. We even found a
microphone in my apartment.
You come with me.
Get yourself lost.
- Okay.
There is a friend of yours here, Johnny.
Hackett, where's Tris?
What about it? Get up.
Harry, frisk him, Irving.
- Yes, sir.
Fifteen.
Chrysler convertible.
License, California.
26-X548
Chrysler convertible.
License 26-X548 has been located.
"Suspect's car has now been
observed by a motorcycle officer."
"Across from the LA Time company.
Between Seven and Central."
SS 742.
Request the officer to stand
by until he can be contacted.
Okay.
You're all washed up, copper.
- Just a minute, Sylvester.
There was more than
one car tailing us today.
They are ready to move in now.
You won't get as far as the
stairs if you pull that trigger.
I'm used to taking chances.
Counterfeiting is one thing.
Murder is another.
Don't put a noose around your neck.
They'll hang the whole lot of you. That
includes you, Laurie. You're part of it.
I'm not part of anything.
- You are part of it, like it or not.
You're in a bad spot, Laurie
and it's going to get worse.
I only came here to
find Tris. Where is he?
I'll tell you. We locked him up because
he didn't keep his part of the bargain.
He tried to double-cross
you and me both, Sylvester.
Don't you see? You can't
even trust your own pals.
It looks like I can't trust anybody.
He had to do it to get out of jail.
That's right. The Police are powerful.
They can make you do almost anything.
Like, talk out of turn.
I guess you are a part of this
and you aren't a plant.
I hate to see you getting in any deeper.
You're in deep enough.
Throw a cordon around the block.
- Yes, sir.
You try that area.
You try that side, John.
0ver here.
You two go with agent Downey.
You two stay with me.
There he is!
Alright, Sylvester.
Put up your hands.
Don't shoot.
Don't shoot!
Sylvester, look out.
Send for the Coroner.
Is that contraband inventory
ready yet on last night's raid?
"Yes, sir."
- Alright. Bring it in.
Have any trouble identifying
he rest of the gang, John?
Not a bit. Those are
faces I'll never forget.
I'll bet you won't.
Put it down over here.
- Yes, sir.
Here is the money and the plates.
And this is the inventory.
Fine.
Sylvester was right.
These are works of art.
$240,000 in twenty-dollar bills.
Feel like counting it again?
No thanks .. I did that last night.
I know every one of
those bills personally.
Everything's in order.
Send these to Washington.
Yes, sir.
Well, I guess that
closes the Stewart case.
-(t-g)-